Okay.
Hey,
so as some of you may know,
I went to give a talk at mcmaster
university on Friday.
Yes.
And,
uh,
it was originally supposed to be a panel
with three other people and also a
moderator and the panelists and the
moderator either chose to or were forced
to buy wild as a consequence of public
pressure being applied to them for being
willing to appear with me on the same
stage.
And so anyways,
I went there and talked and there was a
lot of protesting,
um,
a lot of disruption and that's fine
because people can say what they want
and I suppose they can do what they want
to and I'm not complaining about that.
But,
um,
when I got home tonight,
I found this other,
uh,
missive from mcmaster university,
this organization called,
uh,
pack vic.
And I want to read it to you because it
actually does,
it irritates me half to death.
And so,
um,
I'll,
I'll read,
I'll read it to you and you can make up
your own mind.
March 16th,
2017 statement re mcmaster event
featuring Dr. Jordan Peterson,
professor of psychology,
University of Toronto.
We are deeply troubled.
The Dr. Jordan Peterson has been invited
to speak at mcmaster at an upcoming
event about quote,
freedom of speech and quote and
political correctness.
Most recently,
Dr. Peterson has gained notoriety for
his refusal to use the preferred
pronouns of trans and gender
nonconforming colleagues.
The students at u of t defending his
callous disregard for their personhood
through a misguided deference to his
freedom of speech and his distaste for
political correctness,
but freedom of speech doesn't now it
hasn't ever meant that we can or should
be able to say whatever we like in
public spaces regardless of the impact
of our speech on others.
Instead,
the concept of freedom of speech has
most often been mobilized to protect
specifically counter mnemonic ideas,
ideas that actually challenge rather
than reiterate the status quo.
Freedom of speech was also not conceived
as a means to protect normative ideas
from contact station by marginalized
communities,
but to protect those who speech might
actually contest normative or
nationalist ideals from sensor
punishment or retaliation by state
forces.
There's nothing rebellious or
revolutionary about insisting on the
naturalness of the now long debunked
gender binary or of what Dr. Peterson
describes as quote,
the biological fact and quote of sexual
difference.
Neatly categorizable as quote,
male quote,
end quote and quote female and quote a
quote,
God,
you can hardly read this.
There is nothing rebellious or
revolutionary about insisting on the
naturalness of the open parentheses.
Now long debunked,
closed parentheses,
gender binary or of what Dr. Peterson
describes as the open quote,
biological fact closed quote of sexual
difference,
neatly categorizable as open quote,
male and quote and open quote,
female end quote,
open parentheses,
open quote,
fact closed quote,
subjected to intense critique,
questioning and reconsideration by
numerous scholars in the humanities,
social sciences,
and even the biological sciences for
several decades now,
which demonstrates the limited extent of
Dr Peterson's knowledge on this subject
since he seems either an entirely
unaware of this body of literature or
else unwilling to engage with the
challenge it poses for his own
arguments,
close parentheses.
There is nothing subversive or radical
about suggesting that one ought to be
entitled to read the complexities of
gender identification on the basis of a
quick and unwanted scrutiny of others
bodies and appearance.
This is not a freedom that needs to be
defended,
but rather than simplistic reassertion
of the status quo of ideas about gender
and sexual difference that have become
and stubbornly remained very widespread
and common sensical,
even in the face of mountains of
academic evidence to the contrary and
legislative changes made to protect the
human rights of trans and gender
nonconforming persons.
So let us not pretend the Dr. Peterson
is a staunch defender of any sort of
open quote,
freedom close quote.
What he is defending instead appears to
be his misguided presumption that is
right to uphold the status quo.
Trump's the right of others to exist in
public spaces and be treated with
respect and dignity,
free from hatred and discrimination and
in a world where hate and discrimination
continued to flourish and appear to be
on the rise,
his way of expressing his right amounts
to a presumptive sense of entitlement to
deny others their status as fully and
complex Lee human.
There was nothing new about Dr
Peterson's position.
Then it is a position taken by
multitudes of others before him.
There was also little to be gained by
debating Dr. Peterson because he
presents no argument founded on evidence
that would actually be worthy of debate
unless one is of the view that certain
people are less than fully and calm,
flex a human of course,
and are deserving of being treated with
callous disregard for their personhood
in public spaces,
in which case such views because they
rest on faulty evidence and because they
stand directly in the way of the
substantive inclusion of marginalized
communities in our public institutions
are deeply unsettling and required
critical questioning and contestation
whenever and wherever they articulated.
We stand in solidarity with Trans and
gender nonconforming members of our
communities who have been called upon
repeatedly in the last several months to
publicly respond to and challenge Dr
Peterson's views and to articulate again
and again why are they should be able to
participate fully and meaningfully and
public institutions in ways that reflect
their humanity.
We anticipate that Dr Peterson's talk
will and should result in public
critical opposition to his ideas,
including public opposition to how he's
treated trans and gender nonconforming
people,
which may take the form of public
protest
in the present climate.
Proponents of free speech may try to
paint such opposition.
That's just another indicator that Dr
Peterson's freedom of speech is in fact
under threat.
In fact,
we suggest that were ever free speech is
valued protest to must be valued as a
legitimate exercise of that freedom,
but protest does more than this.
It also leads to articulate and demand
the kind of university and the kind of
society many of us are fighting for one
in which we recognize that speech or
action that reduces the humanity of any
group or people is not an exercise of
freedom,
but instead poses a threat to us all.
Statement issued by the President's
advisory committee on building an
inclusive community's priority and
planning committee and Lgbtq plus
working group that mcmaster students,
union diversity services director,
the McMaster students,
union queer students,
community central coordinator and the
mcmaster students union women and Gender
Equity Neck network coordinator.
Okay,
fine.
So here's the point.
This letter states there is nothing
rebellious or revolutionary about
insisting on the naturalness of the now
long debunked gender binary or of what
Dr. Peterson describes as the biological
fact of sexual difference,
neatly categorizable as male and female,
a fact subjected to intense critique,
questioning and reconsideration by
numerous scholars in the humanities,
social sciences,
and even the biological sciences for
several decades now,
which demonstrates the limited extent of
Dr Peterson's knowledge on this subject
since he seems either leak,
either an entirely unaware of this body
of literature or else unwilling to
engage with the challenge it poses for
his own arguments.
Okay,
no problem.
So this is what I'll say about that to
the members of the PAC buik president
advisory committee on building an
inclusive community.
If you would like to debate with me
about the issue of gender and sexuality,
I'm willing to do that with as many
people as you want to put forward at any
time you want,
at any place of your choosing.
Hopefully sooner rather than later.
And if you're not willing to do that,
and you're going to write cowardly
little letters like this and make them
make them public instead,
I might suggest that if you're unwilling
to defend your ideas of public,
that you should just shut up and go
away.
And I might also suggest that you should
stop teaching students to kind of
nonsense that you are teaching them
anyways.
I don't have much more to say than that,
except I'll just repeat it.
I have no problem defending my ideas
about gender and sexual difference.
And if you guys think that you know what
the hell you're talking about,
then why don't you come out and face me
instead of sending your student proxies
to complain about me when I come to your
university to try to make a case.
I think you're a polling Lee cowardly.
And so I'm calling you out.
Come and debate me whenever you want.
Okay?
Yeah.
Get
me
killed.
You
see,
in this world,
there's two kinds of people.
My friend loaded guns.